let's see um let me just make sure that
uh
ignacio can share screen maybe you
should be co-hosted yes
i did that before i have checked it you
did okay okay excellent
okay well uh uh welcome everybody uh
for for this uh edition of the
colloquium
um so it's a distinct pleasure to have
ignacio here as our speaker today
uh ignacio is um uh
uh has done uh really groundbreaking
work he
you know his work with peter zoller uh
led to the possibility of iron trap
quantum computing
to optical lattices and to uh you know
his work on on that um opened up the
possibility of doing quantum simulations
in in that technology so i cannot think
of anybody better to
talk to us about quantum simulations um
in addition to all this he's
he's done of course really uh
amazing work on on theoretical condensed
metaphysics you know
with the definition of peps and other
tensor networks
um he's uh he's a much decorated
physicist he won the worst prize in 2013
and the
benjamin franklin medal with uh
with with peter zola and so
uh real pleasure to uh
to have you here and looking forward to
your talk ignacio
okay
okay well thank you very much thanks a
lot for the introduction and and thanks
for the invitation it's my
pleasure to be here and to give this
talk about quantum simulation
and uh so first of all i would like to
well i know that there is a mixed
uh audience here from physicists and
computer scientists
and so i would like to apologize to both
of them because
first of all i'm using more of the
language of physics so when i talk about
algorithms and i talk about
computational times then you will not
see this typical notation of computer
scientists but rather
this kind of handwaving notation of
physicists
but i also have to apologize to
physicists because in several times i'm
i'm i'm not going to expect the physics
behind that but i'm going to talk about
i mean how difficult is to solve some
problems in
in in quantum simulations okay in any
case i'm looking very much forward to
the
to the panel discussion afterwards
because we have also several physicists
and
and computer scientists and i think will
be a good mix to to discuss about
quantum simulations
okay so let me start here saying that we
are living now a a a
wonderful area so for people who have
been working on quantum computing for
25 years or longer and there are quite a
few here
then i think that the the dream is
coming uh true
uh so we don't don't have a quantum
computer yet we don't have a scalable
quantum computer yet but we have already
attends
uh what are called analog quantum
computers and
niska quantum computers so these are
devices
which i mean don't behave in the way
that google like to behave because they
have some errors or they are not perfect
or they are
analog but still with them so people
have been able to do
things that otherwise i mean would seem
impossible many several years ago
and some of them go beyond to what we
can calculate so that's an
area in which i mean i guess that
everybody is trying not to
to to see what can be done with these
devices with these analog quantum
computers with these mixed devices
and especially if there is any advantage
in
in
in solving some problems that are
useful for society i'm going to talk
about some particular kind of problems
which are very well suited for quantum
computers in general but also for analog
and nisk devices
and these are quantum many body problems
and these are problems that appear in
physics and chemistry and they
appear in many areas of physics and
chemistry so first of all if you like
to know what are the possible reactions
of the molecule or what is the
geometry of a molecule in space then
you will have to solve one of these
quantum many body problems if you're
studying
solid state physics or you're studying
condensed metaphysics especially at low
temperatures and you will have to solve
this quantum anybody problems or even
you
solve high energy problems and you're
looking at the g minus two factor
of uh miles or
basic particles then you will have to
solve one many body
problem of this kind and so these
problems even though they appear in many
different areas of science they have
something in common so typically if we
want to describe them the first thing
that we do is that we put all of them on
on a lattice
so for the case of chemistry when we
take what are called orbitals
and express everything in terms of these
orbitals without the at the end is
formed like a discrete set
in the case of condensed metal physics
then this is very natural because the
atoms are aligned according to a lattice
and so you want to talk about the
properties of these atoms
and the lattice is already given by
nature in high energy physics this
lattice
lattice is provided just by discretizing
space
and then you what you do at the end is
that you have
some lattice in spatial dimensions in
one two three special dimensions
typically these are regular lattices
even in quantum chemistry of course
this is different and in all these
systems what we typically do is that we
know what is the hamiltonian the
hamiltonian
is what is telling us how the different
laticides interact with each other so
the typical problem
in these systems is that you have a set
of qubits
a line on a lattice interacting with
each other
according to some uh laws which are
given
in the form of a hamiltonian and then we
like to predict
make predictions about this system we
would like to predict if a chemical
reaction will take place we want to
predict
whether a material would be
superconductor will have magnetism or
other properties we would like to uh
predict if the
quarks would form some particles what
would be the mass of these particles and
so on these are
typical predictions and so what we have
to do in practice is that we have to
solve a quantum anybody problem and at
the very end
write what is the state the quantum
state of these systems of qubits
and so at the end when we write what is
this state it will be a linear
superposition of the possible
configurations all
running from all possible qubits state 0
all the way to all possible all the
qubits
in one and the physical properties to
the answer to the question that i posed
are in the coefficients these complex
coefficients in front
of them so in other words typically if
we want to solve any of the problems
that i mentioned before
we will have to find these coefficients
and once we have the
coefficients then we can combine them in
order to compute
this to make these predictions that i
mentioned before
and you already see that the number of
coefficients grows exponentially with
the number of qubits
which in turn grows exponentially with
the volume or the
number of atoms that you have in your
system and so on
and so this means that if you want to
solve this problem with a classical
computer at least if you do it
nicely and exactly then you'll have to
pay a price
in the memories you'll have to use a
memory that grows exponentially with the
number of qubits just to accommodate
all these coefficients in your memory
and if you want to make any prediction
or you want to compute anything
then you will have to do at least one
computation with each of the
coefficients or also
the computational time will scale
exponentially
with the number of qubits so we have
this double exponential exponentially
memory and exponential
in time and while in some problems there
is just an exponential in time
so quantum many of the problems have
this additional property
that that's exponential also in memory
in fact
some people have asked the question so
what happens if i only have polynomial
time
of of of memory what happens if i have
let's say a classical computer with
limited
resources then you can trade time for
a space for memory and then it turns out
that the computational time that grows
like two to the n so typically from
polynomial so two to the n to the power
n
things like that so it grows very very
very fast
so in other words the quantum many body
problems
are especially difficult for classical
computers and that's why
i mean many years ago people realized
that and especially richard feynman and
so he proposed
the field of quantum simulation so he
said well
if i want to solve a problem of in
qubits
instead of storing is a classical
computer what happens if i have
n qubits themselves and what i do is
that i prepare the state of enquiries
then i will not have to use exponential
resources in memory
because i will have to i can store the
state
of the qubits in the qubits themselves
and so
right away you see that the memory if
you use a quantum system a quantum
computer
then will grow linearly with n so that's
already right away
some gain and on top of that then
depending on the problem that you want
to solve so there are different kinds of
problems that you're interested in
then it turns out that the computational
time may run
either linearly with n or exponentially
with m or whatever
but you see that i mean already right
away we have this big advantage
in this in this uh in the in the memory
so that's why quantum computers are
especially suited
for solving quantum many body problems
and that's the obvious application of a
quantum computer because these problems
are relevant in physics chemistry
science
and uh were very difficult to to solve
so what i'm going to talk about is
actually so
algorithms so quantum algorithms for
these manually problems and so these
quantum algorithms
will consider i will be considering
typically a lattice
in in any dimensions i will consider
local hamiltonians meaning that the
hamiltonian the described interactions
in the system
is the sum of terms that are only
locally so there is maybe a term that
acts only
these five qubits here and then another
one attacks and some other keywords and
some other qubits but all of them
are local and so typically you see right
away that
and this uh hamiltonian so the the norm
of this hamiltonian the typical values
of this hamiltonian
will take will be proportional to n so
the bigger the system then the biggers
are the values of the energies that i
will get and there will be some
proportionality factor typically okay so
i concentrate on lattices of whatever
kind
cubits on the lattice even though it
could be higher dimensions and at some
point i will talk about something about
higher dimensions
and hamiltonians that are given which
are local
and these already contains many problems
that are interesting
in physics and if you press me then i
will tell you that even all problems
in physics are like that because if you
have no local interactions
then the underlying theory is local is
always local so
what happens when we have no local
interaction like you have cool of
interactions that i mean decay like
olo is that quantum electrodynamics
actually which is local what you do is
that you simplify your
this hamiltonian and this gives rise to
some effective interactions that decay
uh that are non-non-local so what i'm
saying that only
going back into theory you can always
formulate your theory as local so that's
in that sense it's not a big assumption
okay so
i'll talk about quantum algorithms first
or solving the dynamics so you want to
describe
if i start with some initial states so
what will be the physical properties of
that system after some time
or zero temperature so if i cool this
system all the way to zero temperature
then what would be the properties and
then i'll talk also about
finite temperatures what happens if they
are at finer temperature
and later on so i will
also talk about verification so how the
field of quantum simulation may give
rise
to some verification uh match period of
what
people in berkeley have pioneered of how
you could check that your quantum
simulator is really doing what you're
asking
and so you've got to imagine that you
don't trust it and you want to make
some gain some confidence that somebody
else that has a quantum simulator indeed
as a quantum simulator and at the end
i'll talk a little bit about analog
versus digital so i will talk about
these
advantages and disadvantages of analog
versus digital and that's a little bit
controversial so i hope that this goes
directly
to the to the panel discussion and that
we can address some of these questions
there as well
okay so um i start talking about quantum
algorithms uh dynamics and ground states
then i'll talk about uh finer
temperature then
about verification okay so so what is a
a typical problem in dynamics so again
you're giving leaving your
lattice you're giving your cubits and
you're giving your hamiltonian
you're also giving some initial state
which is it's easy to prepare with a
quantum computer so for example you have
a product state
and then you're also giving some
operators some observable
and at the end what you would like to
compute is the expectation value
of this observable up to some error
epsilon
and of the time of the of the state
which is
timeable according to your hamiltonian
so you start with the easy to prepare
state
then you would like to see what happens
if you evolve it and you compute some
physical property namely some
expectation value
of some observable up to some error
epsilon
actually one of the first algorithms
that was developed was
to solve this particular problem this
was passeth lloyd
in 1996 and so what he did is that he
found an algorithm just to do exactly
that and then he found that the
computational time
and so here when i'm talking about
computational time you may think that
more that this is like the depth of the
of the circuit with the quantum circuit
so the circuit depth
would escape proportionally for a local
hamiltonian like the one that i'm
fitting here
with the number of qubits that you want
to simulate
with the time you want evolve
and uh with the inverse of the uh
error that you are allowed to have
square so
this algorithm has been improved by a
lot during the last years
and so i don't know so typically
state-of-the-art
algorithms have a computational time
which is linear in any linear
in time and logarithmic in one over
this error so these algorithms if you
run them with nisk
then you have to pay a price so this is
not so user friendly for these devices
this is a bit more user friendly for
these devices but still
you have to throttle as the evolution so
you have to decompose the evolution in
many
quantum gates so there is a lot of
overhead engaged
however you had an analog quantum
simulator so maybe
i mean an analog quantum simulator for
the one who doesn't know
is the one it would you take another
system so you're giving this problem
with the lattice and a hamiltonian and
then you take another system that could
be for example
called atoms in optical lattice and then
you engineer
the interactions in your systems well
you first you make
you put them on a lattice physically on
a lattice and then you make them
interact
with each other according to the
hamiltonian that you want to simulate
that's what is called an analog quantum
simulator so you have a quantum analog
simulator then this problem is
trivial you just start your prepared
state and then you do don't do anything
just let it evolve
and then at the end you measure this
observable you repeat it several times
like in the other cases
and by taking the average then you will
estimate
what is the the expectation value okay
so again
the problem of computing dynamics with
analog simulators with these devices or
with quantum computers
is extremely advantageous with quantum
computers
now if we consider another problem
that's the ground state
property problem which is the following
so imagine now that i take my
hamiltonian
and i compute the eigenstates and
eigenvalues so the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of this matrix
and i now want to know properties
about the eigenvector corresponding to
the smallest eigenvalue
so this is what we call the ground state
energy the energy of
the eigenvalue and the eigenvector is
what we call the ground state
so the problem is that you're given the
hamiltonian and you want to compute the
expectation value of some mobile
observable
in the ground state of this hamiltonian
up with some error epsilon et cetera and
you would like to know how this grows
with the
size of your system with a number of
particles
and now the first thing that you notice
here it was not this already
several years ago is that this problem
is very difficult even for quantum
computers
it's in the complexity class you
formulate it in terms of a decision
problem so is there a state with an
energy smaller than something and
up to some one uh polyam error then
is qma hard so it's a is in the class of
uh of problems that we are believed that
are even difficult for quantum computers
and so the computational time in this
case will scale
exponentially with the size of the
system
still i mean this you compare with a
classical computer which would have only
polynomial memory
then still there would be an advantage
with a quantum computer
however for practical purposes this
would not be that
big because you will not be able to
reach big big i mean weak sizes of your
system
now uh what about this coefficient alpha
well this coefficient alpha there have
been many papers that have proposed
special specific algorithms to compute
the ground state let's we mentioned so
one of them that we we proposed some
years ago
and it depends the computational time
depends on what is called the gap
so the gap is just the difference
between the first
eigenvalue and the lowest and the second
eigenvalue
okay so the ground state over the first
excited energy and the ground state
energy that's
how we describe it in physics and the
computational time scale is like 2 to
the power and half so it has to be
exponentially n
divided by this gap and times log 1 over
epsilon so it's already uh
a bit uh puzzling the fact that
typically in classical computers so
people
solve for many years ground state
problems very well
even though they are difficult and but i
mean there are some algorithms that work
in practice reasonably well and
however uh dynamical problems in
classical computers are very difficult
in practice so they're not good
algorithms for that and it turns out
that now for quantum computers it's a
bit the opposite so dynamical problems
are very easy and
i mean ground state problems at least if
you want to solve them exactly then they
are computationally difficult anyway of
course classically
i mean these problems in classical
computers ground state problems are also
computationally difficult
you don't solve it exactly let's say
okay so in any case these algorithms and
many algorithms that people have
proposed
for uh solving this quantum many body
problems
and all of them scale exponentially as
they should but they are not very
practical
for these devices first of all because
of this exponential scaling and second
because they use many and sealers they
use many many techniques
i mean amplitude amplification phase
estimation and so on which is not very
friendly for
these devices or analog quantum
computers
so this is why there are some other
algorithms that are not
that are not let's say exact
they are heuristic that i mean people
are trying that some of them
work well in practice and so one of them
is the adiabatic
algorithm and so that's something that
it's very well known in physics
and that is very widely used actually in
physics for
for many years and the basic idea there
is that uh is to take uh the hamiltonian
and to deform the hamiltonian slowly
so from some hamiltonian which is
trivial to the
problem hamiltonian that you want to
solve and
if you do it sufficiently slow and you
start with the ground state
of the trivial hamiltonian and if some
conditions are fulfilled then you will
end up
in the ground state of the
problem-handling planet that you want to
solve with your quantum computer
and once you have this ground state then
you can perform measurements and compute
this observable
and therefore answer the question that i
told you before so that is what's
represented here so you start for
example
with a hamiltonian that for some
parameter
s that i call s takes the value 0 h of 0
is
a hamiltonian which is it doesn't have
interaction so it's a
single what is called a single particle
hamiltonian is a scene
as a sum of uh hamiltonians acting on
each of the individual qubit
and for which the ground state is just
all uh
qubits in zero and then you start
changing some parameters so that the
hamiltonian depends on s
and at the end when s is equal to one
then you
convert it uniformity into the final
hamiltonian
and if you look at the energy spectrum
as i draw before
like what is given here now as a
function of these parameters or what
will happen is that the ground state now
will change the first excited state will
change
and as long as there is a gap always
between the ground state
and the excited state then the adiabatic
algorithm tells you
that the state will follow adiabatically
your hamiltonian namely it will be at
all times the ground state of the
hamiltonian so at the end of the process
it will be the ground state of your
problem hamiltonian
whenever you do it sufficiently slow and
so that's why
it's uh i mean it's a heuristic
algorithm because
we first of all don't know if there will
be a gap
always it's difficult to prove if there
is a gap in practice
and also we don't know the value of the
gap so maybe the gap gets exponentially
small with the size of the system we
then with the number of qubits and
therefore
the time that we'll take in order to be
sufficiently slow maybe
will be in general exponential with the
size of your system
nevertheless people i mean try that and
in
analog quantum simulation actually
something that people do the people
prepare
stations by using this and uh this uh
adiabatic algorithm and it turns out
that in physical problems
for which so you take now a many-body
problem that appears in physics
for which we can solve it or we can do
computations we can compute these gaps
and even if there are phase transitions
then it turns out that the gap decreases
like one divided by n or one divided by
n squared so they are polynomial and so
this gives
like in practice good algorithms to
solve these
these these problems now this is
um hi ignacio can i just ask a very
quick question so
uh can you help um you know help us
understand
um just just in your in your view
what's the relative importance of
finding ground states versus simulating
dynamics
you know if you had to pick what
independent of the tools available you
know if if we could solve both problems
what what's the relative importance of
them
well i would say that traditionally the
ground state is more
important because there are many
problems uh
so what happens is that income let's say
in condensed metaphysics
and in high energy physics so typically
problems are formulated like
in equilibrium okay so you would like to
know
what is the state of matter that is
interacting with a lot of environment
at maybe a very low temperature and
equilibrium so when it stabilizes and
this is
what we say a thermal state and that's
at zero temperature if it's very low
so typically the dynamics in solid state
physics is not so important it's the
equilibrium part
and the same in high energy physics so
people are interested now
in properties of the of the of the
universe like that
at particles at the moment the mass of
the particles which are related to
the ground state and excitations however
lately with experiments on cold atoms
and
some other systems and trap ions and
superconducting qubits now people are
starting now
looking more at the dynamics and so i
would say that the relevance of
dynamical problem is growing and growing
and growing and so i would say that the
traditional problems is more ground
states
and in uh problems are getting more and
more relevant
the dynamical ones but probably if you
have some other people maybe
they have a different answer
okay so the other heuristic algorithms
are variational
algorithms these are also very very
popular and the
idea there is just to also to start with
the ground state
and then to take a quantum circuit
or an analog quantum simulation in which
there are some parameters that you can
tune
so for example you can tune some
couplings or whatever
now what you do and this is this is
described by some unitary operations
acting on your state
and so what you do is to minimize the
energy
of your hamiltonian the minimize the
expectation value of your hamiltonian
with respect to these parameters and
this may give you
a good let's say approximation to the
ground state against this is heuristic
so nobody
tells you that with the
family of states that you consider you
can get close to the ground state and
nobody tells you that you will even find
it
you know but still that's very nice
because it's
kind of very universal in the sense that
uh even if you
formulate now classical problems that
are encoded in quantum hamiltonians then
you can
i mean apply these variational
algorithms and they are very popular
so in fact i mean for a while we will we
were applying this variation of
algorithms to
this quantum anabolic problems and so we
we faced a
and we were benchmarking them with
numerical methods that exist for this
many body problems so we're taking for
example
a chain what is called a
a one-dimensional lattice and some
hamiltonian
and then trying to uh
simulate how a quantum simulator
would find this we would find the
solution to that problem
and we did it because in one dimensions
there is the mrg there are matrix
products there are many techniques that
work very well
and in practice what happened is that we
needed an enormous number
of uh of measurements
in order to get results which were
comparable to the ones that you get with
classical computers
and these enormous was 10 to the 15 10
to the 16 so it was
completely out of the of the what is
possible from the experimental point of
view
and that's why at some point what we did
is that we combined these two algorithms
so what we did is what we call
variational adiabatic
algorithms in which the idea is to do to
to
to perform the adiabatic algorithm to
find the ground state but to try to
speed it up
just with some variational parameters so
in other words what you can do
is that you can split up this uh
i mean s that parameterizes the
hamiltonian
and then consider let's say different
bunches of time so that you change the
time
that to go it's uh uh to to go from
one value of s to some other value of s
and this is a variational parameter the
time
in which you run the algorithm in the
different bunches and then you optimize
with respect to this
basically intermediate times before
doing that
what we saw is that actually what you
could do is what people also do in
in numerix is first to learn a little
bit
about what is the spectrum that you have
and so for that what you could do
is that you can just take your initial
state run your adiabatic algorithm
and then run the the adiabatic algorithm
backwards
and check you ended up with the state
zero zero zero because it's something
that with a quantum computer is easy to
do
and then depending on the times then you
can find
whether you are in the ground state or
not so there are techniques of i mean
learning about that everything is
heuristic of course and in fact so what
you can do is that for example to
fix what is the time that it requires to
reach this value of s
and come back with a 90 fidelity to the
state
and that's something that you can plot
so then there will be a function of t
so you can find the time that is
requested in order to go back and forth
up to some value of s and then plot this
time
as a function of s for some prescribed
fidelity and this will give you so what
we call adiabatic spectroscopy so this
time
so here we take we take actually the
derivative of this time
and then we see that it resembles uh
very way well the
the cup so that's a way first of
learning about what is the gap of your
system
and once you know the gap of your system
the spectrum
then you can use uh this
uh variational formulation of the
adiabatic algorithm
in order to speed up the process and
what we saw is that for this hamiltonian
that's a typical hamiltonian that we can
solve with some of the methods with the
mrg
and compare so what we saw is that in
order to get
some final fidelity of the state you use
the adiabatic algorithm
this is the total time and if you use
this kind of algorithms
these variational quantum algorithms you
can gain factors of of 10
or something like that so you can speed
up by factors of n
this is for 53 qubits okay so i mean i
think that
well i mean it's it's not let's say
terribly
original i mean they combine these two
techniques but i think that combining
then you can do much less measurements
and
also speed up the variation algorithms
and this this can
this can at least for this first kind of
devices for
solving this ground state of many body
problems it can be this can be useful
another thing that we did in the past
and that we recovered lately
is how to speed up now the adiabatic
algorithms for
particularly local hamiltonians and
for a problem in which you have a
promise gap
so imagine that you want to create some
some state again you want to run the
adiabatic algorithm and then your
promise that the gap
that you will have is larger than a
constant let's say a constant
independent of n
and uh in this constant that we call it
delta
and then if you use the typical standard
adiabatic algorithm you see that the
computational
sorry this is the depth of your circuit
will be proportional to
n and proportional to this constant to
the minus three and the arrow to the
minus one
so it's always proportional to n to the
size of your system
and the reason is because in this
adiabatic algorithm when you compute
uh the computational time and errors and
everything you have to take the norm of
your hamiltonian
and or the derivatives or your
hamiltonian and since you have n terms
you always get these factors of n
so what we found is that if your
hamiltonian is local actually then there
is a way
of getting a poly and uh depth
uh i mean scaling in the in the
computational time
this was done in this paper for
frustration free hamiltonians but we
have generalized now to hamiltonians
and just to tell you what is what is
basically the reason the reason is the
following
so imagine that you have this this
hamiltonian which has n terms that
you're going to change
what you could do is to say well what
happens if i change one after each other
so i first
change the first term then the second
term then the third term
then the fourth term and so on then you
will find
that the error will be n times the error
because you have done
n times something and uh
and uh right then what you could say
what however
if i change the the first hamiltonian
and if
i have a gap then i know that there is a
lip drop in some bound
and therefore things will not propagate
far away so this means that i can change
simultaneously some other hamiltonian
and some other hamiltonian so you can do
things simultaneously
in fact you can just put the leap rope
in some bounce in all that
and then you see that you can do things
simultaneously so you can take
let's say i mean well i mean
basically some pieces of your
hamiltonian and change them at the same
time then some other pieces then some
other pieces and some other pieces and
this would be equivalent as if you do it
one after each other and if you do that
and now at the end and you have to also
derive
and an adiabatic theorem in which
the error scales uh
exponentially down with the time
and if you combine these things it's
very easy to see that then you get this
scaling
okay so it's uh it's an idea of just
uh just taking into account that you
have a
lot a local hamiltonian then you can use
lip robinson bounds and this will give
you
a better a better scaling for the
adiabatic algorithm which will be poly
log n actually is a log n square or log
n one plus epsilon in fact
and compared to the standard algorithm
and i'll come back to that when i talk
about
verification okay so that's
yep there's a question from henry yuan
uh in the chat um which is i think
rather interesting
uh he was asking if there's a
prototypical dynamics problem
that is used as a main application for
quantum stimulation
so is there like some fixed dynamics
problem which is
what actually well there are quite a few
dynamical problems and
and we have uh immanuel bloch after this
uh uh i mean talk in the panel and so he
has done experiments
of uh many body localization and some
some
and misha looking also has done
experiments of uh
time crystals and things like that and i
would say that these are the typical
uh problems for dynamics okay so you
would like to know
how long things tend to take to
thermalize
or that uh i mean if things are
somehow repeating times or get some
periods that are not there
there are people talking about dynamical
phases of matter so i mean these are
typical problems but i would say that
that's not so established like the case
of
ground states because this is i mean
it's been working for 30
50 or 100 years maybe people working on
these united states whereas these
dynamical problems are
appearing now
okay so i'm moving on now to fine at
temperatures and finding energies and
that's i'm going to present some work
that
we do together with cilulu and mary
carmen banunes
and so the idea now is very similar to
the to the ground state problem
and i'm going to present uh two
different uh
uh versions of that problem
so the first is instead of giving you
the ground state i give you some
energy in the middle of your spectrum or
somewhere in the spectrum
and i would like to compute now also
some some
physical properties with respect to in
that state so it's like
before i gave you the ground state and i
told you compute expectation values in
the ground state
now i tell you well i'll give you some
something in the middle of the spectrum
compute the properties of that and the
second problem
is what in physics we do more often
which is to take
a thermal state so what you would like
to do is to compute the expectation
values with some density of operator
which is
completely equivalent to compute the
expectation value
with respect to all possible states in
the spectrum
and at the end weight them with some
exponential decay
so weight is exactly the same thing so
these are the two typical problems so
the first one we would call is related
to what is called the micro canonical
ensemble in statistical physics and the
second one
is related to what is called canonical
ensemble in the statistical physics
so that's the problem and if before
entering into the problem or defining it
more precisely when you notice right
away that this problem is
is difficult i mean it's hard for a
quantum computer and the reason
is because it contains the zero
temperature
state so if i give you the the e0 is the
ground state or if i give you a
temperature which is zero here
this would correspond to the problem of
the ground state that i was mentioning
before
and before we say that this is hard is
qma heart so this problem is also qma
heart so you don't expect
to have let's say i mean the worst case
scenario would be
qma hard however you could also notice
that of course if i start
increasing the energy or if i increase
the temperature
then at some point this may get easy and
actually if i go for example to infinite
temperature
then the problem is completely trivial
and if i go to states
of energy which are close to the middle
of the spectrum this problem
is also typically trivially you
formulated properly
so you see that there will be some
energies at which the problem goes from
difficult to easy
and both classically and quantum but
this position may be different from
classical from
from quantum so it may happen that the
problem is still difficult
for a classical computer but it's uh
it's easy for a classical
for a quantum computer so i want to
discuss this
a little bit and okay so let me talk
first about
finite energies and so that's the
problem
and i give you some energy and uh
now i would like to find the physical
properties but you see this problem is
very ill-defined if i define an energy
because first of all the spectrum is
discrete so if i give you some energy
that probably there is not an eigenstate
exactly this energy this is why you have
to formulate it a little bit more
carefully and also you would like to
scale it
so one way of doing that is to
give you not the energy but to give you
what is called the
energy density namely the energy divided
by
the total number of particles i told you
before that for these local hamiltonians
the energy is extensive so it's
proportional to m so you
divide by n this is what is called the
energy density so i give you
this e value i also give you some
observable
and also i
give you some interval here delta
because i mean uh if i fix the energy
there will be none at any stage so i
have to fix some
some width here delta
and so the the the goal here is to
compute
the expectation value of the observables
in a state
that has this as a mean energy and
that has a variance
which is this delta square so it's a
square here with some prescribed
position
and giving the variance delta so i fix
this variance
i fix this small e and i fix the
observable
and then you like to see what is the
computational time how this scales with
n
epsilon and delta okay you can formulate
it in different ways you can also
take for example as a family of states
that goes with m and then you would like
to compute
with these families and things like that
but that's a way of formulating
and okay so actually this problem is
relevant
in in physics so people are trying to
compute properties
in the what is called micro canonical
ensemble in the middle of the spectrum
and for physically relevant problems
then you will have to scale this delta
as one over n okay that's just keep it
in mind maybe it doesn't matter so much
why this is like that
but that's the the goal so to to scale
the problem to make it bigger and then
we will consider what happens if delta
is like one over n
and see how classical uh methods
compared to
uh to quantum methods okay so that's
something that
uh so people have been actually trying
to solve these problems with with tensor
networks
and in particular we have been trying to
to do that and then we saw
that that's very difficult and so
actually the computational time with
tensor networks
this case like the exponential of one
over delta or the exponential
in and the size of your system
and this the reason is that when you're
trying to get something which is very
sharp in energy
then you're growing it entanglement
grows a lot and so you want to describe
it in terms of tension networks and you
need a very
big one dimension and that's the one
dimensionless case
exponentially with one over the delta so
okay so this means that at least the the
the classical algorithms
that are used for that in one dimensions
actually uh require an exponential time
if we require the delta
scales like one over n that i told you
before okay so now
we're going to consider quantum
algorithms but now in arbitrary
dimensions
and so the idea for the for the
algorithm and
so i'll comment uh each of the points
later on so first of all
is okay so the first thing that you can
do is just prepare
a state which has this expectation value
of the energy that was one of the
conditions and let's imagine that there
is a state
like like that which has this
expectation value of the energy
however typically it will have a much
bigger risk so for example if it's a
product state
that is very easy to show that the
product state for local hamiltonians
you compute what is the energy then it
has a variance that scales like square
root of n
okay so it would have be a huge sigma
would be
square root of n not one divided by n
but the square root of x is very big
so one you have this state then what you
can do is to filter and to make it
thinner and similar and thinner
so that's the second part the cut part
is just apply some operators
and i'll tell you what you can do in
order to make it just of the width
that you ask this delta
and the third ingredient of this
algorithm is that
actually you don't have to do that in
practice so what you can do is what is
called time series for that
and this means that you use your quantum
computer to compute many quantities
which at the end it's equivalent as if
you would have
created the state and done the
measurement so let me explain this with
a little bit more detail
so the first thing take a state that is
easy to prepare
well this is a restriction because this
means that you should be able to prepare
with your quantum computer states of
this energy
and this is a restriction and of course
i mean there must be a restriction
because as i mentioned before i mean
this in general is a qma heart problem
so
you cannot go beyond that
in fact in practice you can take with
product states
and you can show that you can get
some some values of it that you can
reach a small e so these intensive
values now what you can do
is to take blocks so not productive to
cubes but block
qubits and take product states or blocks
and grow the blocks and then you will be
going down in in energy of course
then the preparation and everything will
be get more difficult and so that's
something that you have to evaluate so
how
how far you can get with that but in any
case so that's something that gives you
a restriction to prepare the state
the second the filter you have this
state
that you prepare this p then you like to
apply a gaussian filter
and so this gaussian filter is this a
gaussian operator
which has a width delta in the
hamiltonian
and you see if you apply this operator
what
it will do will be exactly that will
filter it
and however this operator is not unitary
so in practice you will not be able to
apply it
and so but what you can do is to expand
it
in in series
time series and then
at the end when you want to compute an
expectation value of this observable
that was the goal at the end then what
you can do is replace
in these formulas this psi with this
series and you see that at the end
this this is a formula which contains
expectation values
of these quantities and these quantities
so at the end what you can do
what you have to do in your quantum
computer is to prepare your state p
and to measure these kind of locksmith
echoes
this is this quantity so what is the
amplitude that you start with the state
evolved for a certain time
did you go back to the initial state and
if you
do that then you can replace it in this
formula and
then you will be able to compute this
this problem
so now you can check so what is the
computational time
of of that in a quantum computer and you
can i mean
show that it's polynomial in n in one
over delta and one over epsilon
and therefore this should officially
allow you to compute
the properties taking this delta one
over n
no uh beyond what we know with classical
algorithms
of course until some energy which is the
one that corresponds to the state that
you can efficiently prepare
okay so this was the the first algorithm
this is for
zero temperature now let me go to the
final temperature they will be very
similar to that
and so maybe i go a little bit fast
because i want to talk a little bit
about the verification
here so the problem is the same as
before you're giving some temperature
and they would like to compute the
expectation value of some observable
at the given temperature so for this
density operator
and you would like to know how this
grows with the size of your system
and so now what happens is that there is
a classical algorithm that does it
and so i wanted to explain that a little
bit on detail but i i don't have time
so this is quantum monte carlo it's a
classical algorithm that basically
expresses the expectation value
in terms of some expectation some
average
with respect to some probability
distribution so basically what you have
to do
is to sample according to this
probability distribution and then
compute
these expectation values the problem in
quantum monte carlo is that this
probability distribution in order to
compute it
and be able to sample then you have to
solve a many body problem
and so that's hard in general so what
happens is that there are some instances
for which it is possible to re-express
this many body problem in some
particular way
and doing this sampling and then this is
when monte carlo quantum monte carlo
works very well however in many problems
this is not possible it's not possible
to use this trick
and therefore you cannot compute this
easily
and therefore these are the problems
where quantum monte carlo has a sign
problem
and and and when it has designed problem
then
quantum monte carlo takes an exponential
time with the size of your system in
solving these problems otherwise
so typically let's say it's a heuristic
algorithm in any case
it takes a a polynomial time
now so how can a quantum computer help
well
it turns out that you can re-express
also this expectation value
and you can do this trace in terms of
states that are easy to prepare and
then it turns out that at the end what
you can do
is that if you can you can express also
as some expectation value
you're able to sample but now the
probabilities
that you have to compute in order to
sample can be computed with a quantum
computer
it depends on the quantities that i told
you before so again
this algorithm i mean gets around
circumvents the sign problem
in quantum monte carlo it uses quantum
monte carlo and the quantum computer
is a subroutine which computes this
probability in
such a way that you can you can sample
and of course this there are some
requirements is that it cannot go to
uh i mean you have to be able to prepare
the states at the corresponding end and
the energy corresponding to this
temperature and so on i mean there are
some details there
but still i think that is quite quite
interesting that you can
i mean for some cases get rid of the
assigned problem in quantum monte carlo
just by using the quantum computer
as a as a subroutine
okay so i move to the last part of my
talk then it's about
verification that's some work in
progress and so
the idea is uh show how quantum
simulation can be used in verification
and so for that uh i mean let me
introduce very briefly uh
peps i guess that you had some other
talks on on peps
so you have a many body system and a
lattice
then there is there are families of
states called tensor networks
which sometimes approximate well these
many other states they are based on some
tensors they are constructed out of some
tensors that are contracted
according to some indices to each this
many body states so they have
this physical index and the auxiliary
indices
and they are contracted according to the
auxiliary indices in order to give the
manual state
what is important for my talk is that in
any dimensions if you talk about these
peps
there is a subclass of them which are
called injective
in which this map is invertible meaning
that if you consider this sensor as a
map
between these axillary indices or these
black lines and the red line is a map
between the black and the red
if this map is invertible then just call
engine injective
and it turns out actually this is a
generic property so it can be shown
that by blocking lock d where d is the
bond dimension
then generically all peps becomes
injective so it's not a very big
restriction
so i'm going to consider now injective
peps and so what happens with these
injective peps
is that they are the ground states their
unique ground states or local
frustration free hamiltonians
okay so you give me one of these many
body state then there is a hamiltonian
for which this would be the ground state
and this would be the unique ground
state
and so the idea is first to build an
algorithm that would prepare that state
okay so what we want to use is the
adiabatic algorithm that i was presented
before
to start with a trivial state deform
the parent hamiltonian and to end up
with the parent hamiltonian
corresponding to this state
of course for this algorithm to work you
require that there is a gap
and so what you can do is now is well if
you if there is a gap so you can prove
that there is a cup for the whole path
then the time the computational time to
build that will be this poly log
n basically that i mentioned before
because it's a local hamiltonian
but now what we did is that we found a
way of finding lower bounds to
to to gaps and non-trivial lower bounds
of gaps
of these parent hamiltonians and
expressed as a series of n semi
uh sdp problems i mean definite program
problems
so in fact i mean you can show that
there is a range
of uh let's say of hamiltonians around
some ball
around the original hamiltonian that you
will hamiltonian for which you can prove
that
there is a gap and therefore then there
is a sequence there is a series of these
steps that you could efficiently
prepare that's the first part and the
idea there
to prove this and to translate it is to
prove this property in the hamiltonian
this proves that there is a cup and then
we decompose in
sdp problems local sdp problems that can
be officially solved
now the second part is something for a
property of peps that
i didn't know and but that's quite
surprising at least for me
is that actually if you give me an
injective peps
there is i can find a set of observables
and they can compute the expectation
values of these observables
and this set of observable is a complete
set so it's
usually informational completely you
could do the quantum tomography with
them
okay so you give me a peps and then i
can find
i can efficiently find some set of
observable r alpha and s alpha such that
the expectation value for some of them
is one for some of them is zero
these are just written in terms of the
tensors
and they form a complete set so each of
them
goes with b uh let's say you write it in
the poly basis with very complex in the
powly basis
some of them would be simple in the
valley basis but the general one
would be complex in this poly basis and
they form a complete set
and the idea there well i will skip that
so i mean it's a property of these
injecting pips that you can use in order
to compute it
and so this invites you to to propose a
verification
method in which in the standard uh
scenario there is a verifier
that's approver the approver has a
quantum simulator and the verifier
wants to make sure that the prover has a
quantum simulator and that's really
quantum
and so can ask questions the approver
can use if he has the quantum simulator
the quantum simulator
to answer these questions and then the
verifier had to make sure that indeed
the prover has a quantum simulator
cannot do it like with a classical
computer
and so the idea is just using what the
properties that i told you before
is first so the verifier sends the
instructions to prepare the state okay
sends this hamiltonian and cause the
hamiltonian or the adiabatic or the
circuit behind that
so that the prover can prepare the state
and then
the verifier asks pauli operators for
all ops
for all qubits and ask measure this
value operator that cube with that value
operator
and repeat it many times and with many
value operators and the prover what has
to do with the sample so to return the
samples
and once the verifier has the sample for
an
enough number of let's say products of
party operators
then he can check
these observables that i mentioned
before
exactly so he can make sure that these
observables for which he knows
because he's a pep that they have to
have expectation value zero or one they
can check some of them
and and and and check that and
so now okay so what what can one say
about security about that well the first
thing
is that uh okay so something from peps
is is hard actually sharpie heart even
if you have some
some errors and so in general so we
would give
a peps and say sample from these peps
then
the approver i mean should have a hard
time to sample that
however we have a specific set of peps
because these are the ones for which we
can compute the gap
but these ones include the cluster state
and therefore if the verifier would ask
in an integrative way to measure some
clustered tech corresponding to some
quantum circuit
then in order to be to sample correctly
then the approver should be able to to
have a quantum computer to
the power of bqp because has a cluster
state which
could use one-way quantum computation
however
now for that this of course
if he wants to do the whole tomography
so to take random observables for which
you can compute
then many of them will require i mean if
you write in terms of value operators
have an exponential number of operators
and then to check that at the end the
the verified i mean the
the verification would take an
exponential time so still the
the the verifier could make sure that
the prover has a quantum simulator but
it will take an exponential line
to simulate that so this is if he wants
to use a polynomial time then
he wants to take a subset of
these uh samples of this observable that
i mentioned before
for which you can do this computation in
polynomial time
in this course i mean this reduces the
the complexity and this makes it
probably
more uh well that doesn't relate it to
complexity to some complexity class it
makes it
makes it weaker and but i mean
the point that we have is that if you
have an
algorithm that can spoof and compute
these expectation values
efficiently even these ones that can
have a polynomial
number of poly terms then what you could
use
is to build a classical algorithm to
compute expectation values
with peps because if i have a pep
and this injective i could
i could i can compute these expectation
values
and now if you have an algorithm to
fixing this set of expectation value
sampling according to the pauli
basis that you could sample and then i
can use that to compute
the expectation values that i want from
these steps so i think that in any case
it's an interesting problem because
either
it gives you something which is secure
and if it's not secure it will give rise
to some classical algorithm to competing
expectation value softwares
and yeah so i think that my time is up
so very briefly
i wanted to mention something about
analog versus digital quantum computers
and i will just mention one i would say
is
one transparencies so what are
advantages and disadvantages from analog
versus digital
quantum computers okay so analog first
of all they are not
universal so typically you can only
implement certain kind
of hamiltonians with them but not an
universal circuit
for analog quantum computers typically
there is nothing like error correction
so they are not
scalable in terms of error corrections
however they are easy
to build actually i mean emmanuel has
quantum simulators already running for
for quite a few years with having i mean
thousands or hundreds of qubits
now what about the errors and that's
that is a bit more controversial
part so uh it turns out that
in the hamiltonian so you want to have
an analog quantum simulator
then in practice there will be some
errors so this will mean that the
hamiltonian that you want to
uh that you have in practice will not be
the one that you want to simulate
but there would be some small times some
in small terms
but actually there would be n of them
because for each
of the sides there would be one of these
errors so this means that
the error in your hamiltonian is
extensive or the norm
of the error would be much larger than
one when it is large
and so one would say that if i have an
error that is so large then i will not
be able to
observe anything with that however it
turns out that in practice
in many of these experiments what they
are interested is in uh
observables that are intensive so they
are interested in something like the
magnetization
per particle because you want to compute
some averages per particle
and it turns out that these errors that
they get
are related to this epsilon not epsilon
times n
and so you would say and so why so where
can this be used
and is this true what you're saying well
i mean let me tell you some something
that is an evidence
because this is an experiment carried
out by emmanuel bloch many many many
years ago in which he was doing
kind of quantum simulation so he had to
simulate the boss howard model that's a
hamiltonian this would be this
hamiltonian
in practice he had some errors and these
errors were extensive
so this was of the order of 5 or 10 0.1
or something like that
and at the end the physical question
which is uh that one wants to address
is whether if you change the parameters
of your hamiltonian there is a phase
transition
namely that the properties change
abruptly and then
this is what he observed directly just
by looking at the experiment whatever
this is
then you see that if you change the
parameters there's an obvious phase
transition
and so even though at the end the
hamiltonian
is not perfect has extensive errors he
was able to answer the physical question
which is relevant
in a very efficient way and so that's
why of course this is
in from complexity theory that's not
formulated as a complexity theory but at
the end you want to solve a problem is
there a phase transition
is there some order parameter is this
physical property and for these quantum
simulators these analog quantum
simulators
then even if there are errors then you
can still be able to solve one of these
problems and i think that with that i
will finish
my talk just by going to the
to the acknowledged serious uh
mentioning the people who were involved
in the variational algorithm
is benjamin and jordi and they speed up
uh
adiabatic demand
finite temperature marie carmen and
sirius blue and verification was fabio
ester norweg and jordy
and many of the things that i have
talked about here i discussed with with
misha lukin who is doing some
experiments on adiabatic and many other
things so
a lot of collaborations with him so
thank you for your attention
great thank you thanks uh ignacio
um there were a couple questions maybe
that we should take first
now now is a good time
so dan stamper kern had a great question
of
can one use the advantage of a quantum
computer to conduct time
dependent calculations in imaginary time
in order to also find the ground state
efficiently
actually not so they have been
algorithms that do that and their
exponential i mean they
they they go
the computation the computational time
grows exponentially so the fact
that if you take imaginary time then
this is not a unitary operation and the
thing that you can do with your quantum
computer is unitary gives you this
overhead that is exponential
and there's one other question by shiva
prasad omonokuten
which was you mentioned the role of
temperature to the hardness of
simulating a quantum system classically
but what about the role of decoherence
in the hardness of simulating classical
well uh you have well
i mean you have dynamics with the
coherence then it can be officially
simulated
that's something that was shown many
years ago and the other thing is that if
because you have the coherence
then probably you cannot get the right
result in quantum simulations or even
you have the coherence you will have
entropy you want to find what is the
ground state of the system then you will
never
be able to find the ground state you
will find something that may be close in
some sense but it will not be
so depending so simulating the coherence
is efficient
however working against the coherence
it's it's
it's it's bad however as i mentioned
before
at the end for an analog simulation for
some of the properties that you're
interested in physics these are
intensive quantities if the amount of
the coherence
is still i mean reasonable then you can
still
be able to answer those questions
uh great uh just last question just
check showed up in the chat
david ding asks uh given the current
state of experimental quantum computers
what is the outlook for realizing your
algorithms
well we are collaborating now with with
some uh
experimentalists and in doing that and
so one of the
one of the questions is how how the
errors uh uh will affect them
and so that's something that we are
really looking at so we did some
simulation with errors in our the paper
that we wrote
and we were very optimistic but now we
have to when we're talking
we're talking really about uh
experiments that we will be done in the
in the in the lab with super conducting
qubits in fact
and this is this is uh when you start
thinking about experiments
it's hard okay so let's see
great i think those are all the
questions i saw in the chat if i missed
any of them
please unmute and ask right now i guess
great time so maybe maybe we should uh
we should let's let's thank ignacio
again for this uh for a wonderful talk
and we can now move on to the
panel so